YOUNG DICTATOR IS ABOUT TO DO
NEXT.
A DANGEROUS ESCALATION BETWEEN
KIM JONG-UN'S REGIME AND HIS
SWORN ENEMY.
SOUTH KOREAN FORCES ALONG THE
DEMALL TARRIZED ZONE DETECT A
PROJECTILE, LIKELY A ROCKET,
FIRED TOWARD A SOUTH KOREAN LOUD
SPEAKER SYSTEM.
THE SOUTH KOREANS RESPOND WITH
36 ARTILLERY SHELLS.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO U.S.
OFFICIALS WHO SAY THEY'RE
CLOSELY MONITORING THIS TENSE
STANDOFF.
>> IT RAISES QUESTIONS, FRANKLY,
ABOUT KIM JONG-UN'S STYLE OF
MAKING TENSION, PROVOCATIONS,
ESCALATION, AND WHETHER HE KNOWS
HOW TO COL ESCALATION.
>> Reporter: STRESS HAS BEEN
BUILDING FOR WEEKS.
U.S. AND SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS
BELIEVE THE NORTH KOREANS
STARTED IT ALL BY PLANTING LAND
MINES ON THE SOUTHERN SIDE OF
THE DMZ.
AN EXPLOSION AUGUST 4th NEARLY
KILLED TWO SOUTH KOREAN
SOLDIERS.
SOUTH KOREA RESPONDED BY
RESUMING LOUD SPEAKER BROAD
CASTS TOWARD NORTH KOREAN
SOLDIERS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
DECK TADE.
MESSAGES TELLING THEM KIM
JONG-UN'S DOING A BAD JOB AND
THERE'S A BETTER LIFE IN SOUTH
KOREA.
AND THIS WEEK A MASSIVE SHOW OF
FORCE BY THE U.S. AND SOUTH
KOREA.
SOME
SOME 30,000 U.S. TROOPS, 50,000
SOUTH KOREANS, ENGAGING IN
PREVIOUSLY PLANNED MILITARY
EXERCISES.
ONE OF THE AREAS SCHEDULED FOR
LIVE FIRE DRILLS IS NEAR THE
CITY OF POCHANG.
>> ROUGHLY HERE, COMPARED TO
SEOUL DOWN THERE.
>> WHY SO CLOSE TO THE DMZ AND
POSSIBLY PROVOKE THEM?
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
NORTH KOREANS UNDERSTAND WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING THESE
EXERCISES REAL WITH THE SOUTH
KOREAS AND US.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A LIVE FIRE
EXERCISE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TROOPS
DOING DRILLS WITH ACTUAL
WEAPONS, WITH BULLETS.
>> Reporter: THE DRILLS PROVOKED
A THREAT FROM KIM'S REGIME,
IMPLYING THEY COULD HIT THE U.S.
HOMELAND WITH A NUCLEAR-TIPPED
MISSILE.
U.S. OFFICIALS AND ANALYSTS SAY
THE NORTH KOREANS DON'T HAVE
THAT CAPABILITY.
BUT THERE'S STILL CONCERN
TONIGHT OVER THE JUDGMENT AND
TEMPERAMENT OF A 32-YEAR-OLD
DICTATOR.
>> THE PATTERN CLEARLY SHOWS
THAT KIM JONG-UN, EVEN MORE THAN